pis très pragmatique je me suis battu
pour qu'on ait un processus qui
choisissent notre candidat les primaires
ça a été décidé par le parti socialiste
très bien maintenant je considère que
toutes les candidatures sont légitimes
perdu c'est à dire que si le président
de la république souhaite se présenter
et il est tout à me fait fondé de son
point de vue à le faire et j'ajoute une
fois que j'ai dit ça que pour l'instant
pour moi aucun des candidats soient
déclarés soit supposé ne s'impose
naturellement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que notre primaire sera utile on a des
femmes et des hommes qui ont leurs
qualités leurs défauts nature y est mais
non c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi un
processus pour le trouver quelle est la
primaire c'est à dire ça veut dire aussi
que l'offre est assez fan fie aux femmes
et aux hommes de gauche la possibilité
de le faire avec nous